The four values produced are X, Y, Z and W. These are called homogeneous
coordinates and they're used for projection. What we do next with these
coordinate values is divide each value by the W of the coordinate. This is
called the prospective divide or homogeneous divide. So for our three test
points we had a value such as 0, 0, negative 1, 1. Dividing by 1 is simple
enough. That gives us 0, 0, negative 1. We don't need to bother writing out the
W value in the results, since W divided by W will always equal 1. For our next
point, W is 11. Dividing all these coordinates by 11 gives 0, 1, 1. Our last
point is a little more interesting. Dividing through by W gives us 0, 0.67,
0.83. Here are plots of the original points and view space and their
corresponding new locations. Notice that the negative Z axis is pointing to the
right for the frustum, and the resulting axis is plus Z to the right. Look at
what's happened with these points and where they're transformed. They started
inside or on the edge of our frustum. After the projection matrix is applied
and division by W is performed the resulting points are in normalized device
coordinates, anything in the range negative 1 to 1 for X, Y and Z is in the
visible view volume. Let's take another example to show what happens to three
objects that are the same size in world space but at different distances. When
we transform to normalized device coordinates the relative area of coverage of
the near plane stays the same. That is, the close object was half as high as
the screen in our frustum view and transforms to half the height in NDC space.
The second object is farther away and shows up as smaller. The third object on
the back of the frustum is indeed much smaller than the others in normalized
device coordinates. You might have noticed an interesting thing has happened to
the depth of the second object. It started in the middle but it's moved
backwards. We'll talk more about that in a bit as it's important.